vite et philippe bélair secrétaire
général de la cgt sont égaux a loupé un
bon jour philippe bélair merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
la situation est telle en guadeloupe que
des mesures radicales comme le couvre
feu devait être prise bonjour je vous
remercie
en guadeloupe la situation c'est comme
diriger les autorités sanitaires et
préfectorales en décidant décrété que la
situation est grave mais nous ce n'est
pas notre lecture
nous nous estimons que et on l'a déjà
dit on le répète on va leur marteler aux
tard possible que c'est la stratégie qui
a été mise en place qui fait que
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation compliquée les compliqué
certes mais elle n'est pas aussi grave
que le dise ces autorités
nous nous étions pourtant les mesures
prises comme étant une volonté d'imposer
ce qu'on appelle la vaccination parce
que pourquoi parce qu'en fait en
guadeloupe il ya 15 % seulement de la
population qui a accepté de se faire
injecter les produits que nous qu'on
nous présente comme étant des vaccins à
notre analyse c'est qu'il y à d'autres
qu'aux stratégies thérapeutiques
il y à d'autres formes de prise en
charge qui peuvent être mises en place
et que le gouvernement les autorités
locales rechignent à mettre en place
alors que ça revient à moins chère alors
que sa vie très justement de mettre à
plat les toute une économie toute une
population toute une société
ça philippe bélair vous parliez à
l'instant de la vaccination en
guadeloupe 1 17% de la population a été
vaccinée complètement vous parler
d'autres solutions à la vaccination
quelles sont ces solutions justement
dont on entend parler en guadeloupe
alors pas seulement voix de lopins il ya
une espèce d'omerta qui est fait sur
tout ce qui est
traitement en amont par exemple utilisé
en médecine le fameux variant delta et
qui vient d'elle a été traitée
radicalement à leur médecine on le sait
on en une taxe de complotiste en taxes
de toutes sortes de finalement nous pour
nous bien et c'est une affaire de
liberté publique compte qu'il ya des
gens qui ne rechignent à se faire
vacciner avec un produit à base d'arn
parce que c'est une technologie nouvelle
il ya beaucoup de soignants qui estime
que qu'il vaut mieux attendre que
effectivement on n'a pas assez de recul
et que la responsabilité de ceux qui
produisent ces produits là elle a été
complètement écartée donc tout ça ça
fait ça fait craindre alors qu'il y à
d'autres qu'aux méthodes possibles il
fallait qu'il y ait une grande panoplie
fallait qu'il y ait qu on offre à la
population et particulièrement aux
soignants qu'on leur offre tous les
moyens possibles tous les moyens
nécessaires pour qu'ils puissent
commander religieux évoluer avec ce
virus là je rapelle que au début de la
crise de l'an dernier il n'y avait rien
en envoyait les soignants à mains nues
pas seulement elle soigne d'ailleurs les
accompagnant les élèves domicile on les
envoyait à mais lui je vous rappellerai
ça a maintenu sa veut dire que il était
quasiment seul tu le terrai affronter
sens en blues s'en suit ou bleu sang
sans grand sans masque sans traitement
sans rien du tout ils haïssent vit à
l'ère où au fond et ma foi ils se sont
débrouillés et ma foi il n'y a pas eu de
google le casse énormément parce que le
bon sens avait nié les gens puis leur
mesure de précaution les gens savaient y
sont soignés ils sont accompagnés ils
savent que à partir du moment où il ya
un danger il faut savoir se protéger des
gens étaient très professionnels sur le
terrain et c'est ce qui a sauvé ces gens
là et aujourd'hui on
en traite ces gens là comme si c'étaient
les parias non il faut qu'on arrête
nous ne sommes pas des parias nous ne
sommes pas des commandants jeu on ne
doit pas nous mettre à l'index parce que
simplement parmi nous il y avait
certains qui estiment parce que je
rappelle aussi qu'il y à beaucoup
beaucoup qui se sont vaccinés vous
interrompre puisque le premier ministre
en déplacement ce matin à jeun parle
d'une situation quand même dramatique
dans les antilles vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la stratégie sanitaire en
guadeloupe qui serait responsable de la
situation aujourd'hui qu'elle était
justement cette cette stratégie
sanitaire qui mène à la situation qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui dans les antilles
c'est à dire que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
depuis le début jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est la même exactement la même et on a
l'impression que on est dans l'entonnoir
est ce qu'on veut c'est simplement que
tout le monde se vaccine la même pour
ckoi si on ferme le couvre-feu c'est ça
en permanence et ça c'est pour vertu
fermetures et ouvertures fermetures
fermeture voilà on a l'impression qu'on
joue avec les nerfs des gens pour
simplement les mettre dans le tournoi
pour qu'ils acceptent un moment donné la
vaccination à la rl c'est tout point
barre
alors que maintenant la bientôt on aura
des vaccins classiques des vaccins que
les soignants connaissent parfaitement
bien qu'ils pourraient être acceptés je
vous rappelle une chose ou du moins je
vous informe si vous n'êtes pas informé
sais c'est que nous avons une île à côté
là l'île de la dominique qui a 200 km
ils sont à peu près à moitié ils ont
assumé la moitié de la surface de la
guadeloupe que la moitié aussi de la
population il n'y a pas mort il n'y a
pas eu depuis plus d'un an
parce qu'ils ont pris le bon sens ils
ont choisi une orientation de bon sens
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont fermé les
frontières qu'ils ont contrôler
strictement et pourtant ils n'ont pas
d'hôpitaux comme nous et pourtant ils
n'ont pas le scientifique comme nous et
ils ont fait le nécessaire et
aujourd'hui ce pays là c'est pas fait
partie des rares pays où il n'ya pas
seulement parce que ces gens là on
s'ennuie en place une stratégie face à
la pandémie qui relève du bon sens du
bon sens médical
merci philippe bélair d'avoir est avec
nous on vérifiera bien sûr cette
information sur un communiqué merci en
tout cas d'avoir avec avec le cas
dominique vous avez
vous avez raison de le rectifier merci
j'ai pu utiliser l'air d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgt santé
guadeloupe merci beaucoup